your show is a phenomenon it's a very
edgy show
does the network ever come to you and
say we like it it's very popular
but let's just tone it down a little bit
yeah well on the page at first glance
the scripts could be
officially porno films yeah um yeah they
are they are definitely
loosely based on the things we see on
the internet
i hate to let the cat out of the bag and
tell everyone where we get our secrets
but
internet porno yep pornhub brassers
yep you go on porn sites and that's
where you get your
plots oh the storyline yeah acting tips
yes grooming grooming is the big one for
you
ball andy and i have learned timing from
pornography oh yeah oh it's good
it's how you learn things that's how we
got a lot of our catchphrases keep it
sleazy tight butthole
yeah that's the famous one okay
fantastic catchphrases by the way he's
like they're serious
oh we're cutting this whole section out
no no no uh it'll be a weird old card
with you with just
a ton more hair and ten more yeah yeah
yeah yeah well we'll cut to me from
1994.
yeah nice tea i'm just curious like you
do have these
these these these crazy catchphrases you
nutty kids you
tight butthole do you have fans yelling
tight butthole at you
weirdly enough like one of the very
first times i was ever recognized which
is weird when you start to like
get recognized it's kind of scary and
this guy i was stopped at a stoplight
which i do most times
um sometimes i don't though sometimes
when i kill them all but this time i
stopped
and this guy walks across and he stares
at me just like this he's like
adam adam and i didn't know what to do
so i just did this i went
yeah which is the dumbest thing that you
could possibly
awful what an awful thing you did and
then he just goes you got a tight
butthole man
thank you which is out of context yes it
is it is he's not using it
properly it's like you're you are being
tight butthole like cool or whatever not
you have a type yeah he was talking
about the actual
tightness of my rectum yes which is
probably pretty tight
yeah so he was you know the problem is
people who don't know the show who are
what bystanders are thinking there's a
guy
comment commenting it's not good there's
just a father and son
dad what is he talking about well the
two men love each other
yeah i didn't think i was gonna have
this conversation when you were six
on the street you guys are i'll get
right to it you're naked a lot on the
show there's a lot of
you guys without clothes on the show
thank you
[Laughter]
what uh was this is this a societal
statement you're making well
if i mean we want to be the male lean
and dunham's i think that's what we're
going for
uh if if comedy central was hbo
we would just be penis out all day long
but they won't i mean it adds it adds a
little something it's adds a layer
that's a layer of commodore wiener's out
all day yeah yeah
that's what you get when you get most of
your ideas from uh or no websites yeah
so but you're also oh go ahead sorry
well to be fair like there are about
like four episodes coming up in the
season that are completely just about
the male genitalia
yeah stay tuned we don't know any better
we don't uh what about the fact that
you're
under the influence a lot your
characters on the show our characters
yeah our characters
yeah yeah right i just fall asleep
yeah what do you got in that cup uh what
do i have in my hair
yeah what is this hidden joints in the
hair i think it would have been
like a it was like more of a big deal
when we first started
like three years ago but now like weed
is just so normal
in california that you really have to do
something flagrant
in order to get caught up you really
have like
they don't like cops probably see snoop
dogg smoking all the time they're like
hey there's snoop the homies know
in california you'd have to take the gun
off of a cop's holster
pack the barrel full of weed and then
like smoke out of the cliff
and then he might arrest yeah and then
they go yeah yeah
you have to take it to that level yeah i
think so and the cop would be like i
don't want to have to do this man
that that that could be our like blue
comedy tour thing like
you might get arrested yeah you might
get arrested
if if you steal the mace out of a cop's
little pouch
and lace your weed with it you might get
arrested
that's a good merch idea yeah